how do I start a flower shop business I
got a great question for one of our
readers Jay who wants to start a flower
shop business and there's so much as
going right with what he's doing right
now that I had to share with you guys
there's a lot of lessons here that you
can learn from now Jay wrote almost an
essay here so Jay we got to work on
condensing our message here but
basically wants to start this business
because for him it symbolizes stability
peace of mind because the garden calms
him down and freedom he wants to make
money through the business he wants to
hire his mother and people in this
family to make the bouquets he's trying
to get this started he wants to
bootstrap it up he is trying to find
unique angle where he's collecting small
fruit trees and little fig trees trying
to find something different and he's
trying to start small he's trying to
think of ways to start on a website
buying something from flippa and getting
his business started online before
moving into his own store so this is
great there's so many things that's
going right for Jay right now Jay you
don't even understand how awesome this
is my advice for you first tune into
your messaging okay you're starting this
business for the right reasons you
didn't write insane I want to start this
business because I want to make a ton of
money right you do that you're going to
fail you're starting this business
because you passion believe in what
you're doing and thinking about what you
wrote here stability peace of mind
because it calms you down and freedom
the thing that relates most to your
customers here is a peace of mind and
calm so build your business around calm
everything that you do should be calm
and you want customers to come in who
want to feel calm just like you do it's
something you can relate to share your
story talk about how stressed out you
are and how a garden makes you feel calm
and why and you're going to bring in
customers who feel the same way so now
you're not just a flower shop you're not
just one of a million flower shops out
there you're the guy who sells calm
that's powerful that's something people
can get behind
so everything that you do in your
messaging in your product selection
everything is about being calm this is
how you pour yourself into your company
have something that is a message that
can be spread easily brings in the right
target audience for you and will lead to
your huge success as a flower store
owner so build it around comp this is
great
second thing is you got to have
something that's unique and different
your product offering okay so you're
talking about these seeds fig trees
unique fruit trees you know I don't know
anything about flowers or fruit trees
but it's great that you're doing
something different because you can't
just sell the same flowers that
everybody else is selling once you've
convinced people that you are the place
to go for calm everything that is in
your store has to be related to it so
what fruit trees or fig trees or flowers
what is it about a garden that makes you
feel calm and how can you bring that out
in your product offering everything has
to relate to it and has to be different
and you have to be able to explain it
what is it about a fig tree that makes
you feel calm that will make other
people feel calm as well about growing
the fig tree about harvesting the figs I
don't know what it is a fig tree doesn't
mean calm to me but you got to explain
that you have to believe it and people
will then come and buy from you the
coming not just to buy a fig tree
they're coming for advice on how to be
calm so it's great to have this unique
product offering the third thing is
starting small bootstrapping it so
you're starting with the website that's
great your end goal is to have a retail
shop what I would add on top of it
including the website because with a
website you're pulling from an
international audience right anybody in
the world can buy your your you know buy
your calm fruits and plants for a retail
store you need to pull from a much more
specific geographic location so still
find a way to test it out in a small
scale come up with you know ten plants
that symbolized calm for you whatever
those ten things are and then go try to
make a partnership with a local business
where you are not taking on a huge
retail space storefront taking up tons
of money and resources for you on a
monthly basis and who knows it is going
to work out
you're not McDonald's if you go and
invest in a location it doesn't work out
that's huge for you
right this is everything McDonald's they
can lose a franchise if it doesn't work
out you can't afford to make a mistake
here you have to pick the right location
and the way to do it is to start small
and partner up with an existing retailer
ask them if you can set up a table
inside their store either on a permanent
basis or you're paying them a monthly
fee a small fee to test out the location
or on a weekly basis maybe you come in
every Saturday afternoon and you sell
your flowers and it could be something
where they where you pay them for it or
where they split the money coming in or
it could just be for promotional reasons
you know you're going to be outside
selling your flowers every Saturday
afternoon and that's going to bring a
crowd it and you're going to help
promote it and bring people into their
business at one of the salsa companies
that I've invested in we'll have events
and we'll have different retailers come
and display things outside the store so
for example we may have 100 people show
up to a salsa night at the studio and
we'll partner up with a shoe company who
sell salsa shoes and they'll sell their
shoes outside our location that's within
a mall they don't pay anything to us for
it
all we ask them to do is promote it
bring bring your people say you're going
to be here and that helps our business
as well so you may not even have to be
able to pocket try to get going here
without spending money so you're going
to promote their store what it allows
you to do is a couple things most
important here you're testing your
location this store that you partner up
with if you do you know four weeks in a
row eight weeks in a row nothing is
happening no business is coming in
despite all the promotion you picked a
crappy location and thank you for not
having gone out and Spain
tons of money into a five-year lease
creating your own flower shop it also
teaches you the beginnings of running a
business if you've never done it before
it's hard there's a lot of things you
have to learn you can have to figure out
how you're going to bring people on
board how you're going to source your
materials how are you going to display
them you're going to make tons of
mistakes you're doing it on a small
scale so if you make a mistake it's not
going to kill your business and it
allows you to do a part-time you can
keep at your job have some kind of
stable income coming in give your
company the best chance of success
because you're not going to run out of
cash and lastly let's see if you really
like it
it all sounds great you have the passion
you have the calm meaning it sounds like
you really want to do this once you get
into it you'll see if you really want to
commit to it or not and it's best to do
it on a small scale Jay I'm excited
you've got so many great things going
for you don't even realize it all the
elements already here
keep going believe in yourself and if
you have other questions let me know I'm
here to answer believe for those of you
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below it makes me to do
more for you and I'd love to hear what
you have to think about this video leave
it in the comment section below it makes
my day when I see comments come in and
if you have a question for your business
leave it below i'll make a video reply
for you guys thank you and i'll see you
soon